mmm got a Woma warm-up knowledge no not
like that not like your gargling ball
you got oh I did screaming aah
harmonize with me oh hello old person
who lives in this house
I've seen her falling into a pit of
despair could you help me
no ma'am ma'am another ma'am oh oh oh he
died once what is my name
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Dark Souls 2 with--we day
guys we yeah we're here to play this
game that you guys have been requesting
for days and days and weeks and weeks
ever since the release of the game I
don't even know what the hell I just did
but I'm just looking forward to all the
things this is where we're starting the
game but there was actually a cutscene
before this but it was very long and
that's really the point of why you're
here you're here to see us lives our
minds as we play this game right yeah
mark died trying to cross a bridge died
there let's show footage of that all
right but there was this dude I fall off
there first death yeah I'm in it here
Wow some ah I'm really I am a jackass so
anyway we're gonna we're gonna pass off
the controller over to death so we're
gonna try to recall her name oh my I
thought you
Oh
Jagr like my first girlfriend in high
school
Oh Smitty we're bear yard hahahaha
how do I make it go I wanted to say yes
I would like that letter one oh no
that's the maximum
okay we're smitty werben yam who's with
you her yam alright let's go we go ah
give it back
oh that's 12 we're lonely weber yam
we're Smitty where were ya so if you see
Smitty wherever y'all if you look behind
me whatever y'all that's us oh that
barely covers our junk okay what's my
class oh my god that is a lot of class
what deprived
Oh God that got me some more ah that'd
be a very dumb decision no way I want to
but I know I actually do want to do
something night it is yeah oh my
goodness oh yes yes whoa that's two
sofas it's offensive it's our camp
you're laughing at that poor lady model
thing with no hair buddy
it was awesome yeah because it was
offensive just cuz you have to take
offensive things doesn't mean that it's
offensive
why you gotta be so mean damage our
artists right and there that's a good
tent you later
that's beautiful we look good while
they're all just chuckling themselves
creepily can we get to the death yet
yeah oh yeah oh so dramatic me oh my
good it maybe we should restart from the
woods what do you what'd you just do but
I just do how do I know stop it I'm uh
I'm paid to do okay there we go okay so
the right mouse button is swinging my
sword left mouse button is I don't know
cuz I'm opening the door okay it's block
left man
do that house button whatever its
control or I don't know out of what I'm
doing I'm not you are woman lighting a
bonfire whoa I don't know what that
means I don't know either crested
bonfire we can turn burn what am i
burning don't ever do it all right
and why doesn't oh but maybe you can
only carry so much all right whatever
I'm out of here baby
I'm off to an adventure let's see how
far I get before my first death I'm
ready for it I'll be careful play my
cover with one you can follow the edge
oh you're being weak
you mean I could fall this I don't
anymore like you just topple over the
side you worried about this is not gonna
end well
hey we're laughing now it will be
laughing a little bit uh there's not
even a monsters game is still hard easy
yeah see we promote leave add add good
what give us your worst game yeah
bringing a little boss right now can't
work professional gamers as you know
already light oh it's lovely its tumble
towards it hello you're good tumble a
diva hula we're on the Mikula Matata
woohoo Louboutins shut up that's
copyright copyrighted song day yeah I
recovered it did you I did you really
did a good job
mom where's the enemies I want to die
repeatedly over and over again because
that's what people want me to do
apparently new enemy they want to see
you try to well and then just fail oh
haha Wow
what did you think was gonna happen
maybe it wasn't that deep there seem to
be a lot of dead bodies in there yes
long what about the same stupid ha ha
Cass this is gonna happen every every
time this is why people rage it's the
loading screw walkie I didn't even die
from anything else this is one much whoa
what happen to me what did happening
what happened to me oh my oh my goodness
gravy if you should kill yourself I
don't know what happened but I'm gonna
go this way now because there's a goose
Teague here yeah for the Miss I saw so
dr. I so want to enter the mist yeah I'm
not as scary oh your actual thingies
glad I got a blocker what's that that my
placard
no run away I got I got it I got it I
get this I gotta wait for him down Oh
aah wait that was not right look how I'm
not blocking anymore oh my god that'll
happen
oh I switched to two-handed okay yeah Oh
you miss me now I'm gonna slice you up
better lighting your but I will just
killed two monsters I look at your
health on the bus but I got a laugh Jam
because I'm cool you're welcome you
won't I heal myself it wasn't slowly
regenerate
oh I didn't see that how could I just
neither can I even jump I don't you know
Julia the thing I can do
I didn't god damn it mark Coggan loading
screen
ah we're gonna get loud here yeah it's
about to get loud yeah I can't wait till
we do that again I'll die one more time
than you can play oh good all right
we're looking today alive uh look good
he did it
oh yeah yeah yeah cuz it's all now right
there hey hi hello there
okay I'll leave it or not I'm a
beautiful woman oh they're all get a
better woman
Lily oh yeah yeah I would if you're
gonna look progressively worse and worse
the more you die I don't know I don't
know if I look worse than I did the
first time
hey there's miss over there let's go
there yeah that'll be a good idea she's
not fall off any edges this time just CD
I did know them oh okay you want some
ice what what sauce it's on us bro oh
what's that oh oh counter down kill him
yeah very good cool thank you very much
for that okay watching for pants what
kids no no no no oh so good so good yes
yes you suck but so far so good this
time
game is easy did we actually set it on I
saw him a mile away
OOP huh huh wait for it wait for it tell
me wow dougen there's a death KC dude
they're still doing damage but you're
blocking how about you stop being such
oh god oh god oh how do I get there
don't jump off there's only ledges okay
oh here we go there's a weight
immediately to the left
oh hello buddy what can expose nice nice
that was good thank you that was all
skill I had to press like ten button
cops actually see some progression thank
you thank your welcome are we always
gonna have to respond from the same
place even if we die far they don't
worry though I got a dagger is it better
how do you go you're gonna like I'll
select start I don't know oh oh got a
bow and arrow ain't gonna hurt me cuz I
got a sworn in a mean look on my face
oh hello where'd you come from oh Christ
whoop deep aren't you dead
this is easy so far so hey IRA people's
in his art you should use your life gym
but you're like I am yeah even if I'm
blocking they still hurt me a little bit
yeah got life gems so good in this
neighborhood six life gym Wow
sneak attack you or maybe I'm not oh oh
you you arrowed your own teammate
don't let kind of like a giant brick
whoa you were about to stab me but I got
you in the boy nice oh oh I didn't those
writings like that ah yay okay I fell
but not into a precipice of death am I
always gonna be like this from now on
because I died so early in the game I'm
not permanently ugly okay which way am i
are you looking better I can't tell Oh
No damn what are you talking flesh on
the top way you're talking about way
don't you think I am beautiful you're
gorgeous
kick why would I kick the letter down I
think it was like an extension that
needed to go all the way done okay that
makes Moses like [ __ ] check that your
stupid ladder though god I'll kick you
could use your get out okay
it was a big thing in I don't know like
I'm going around in a lot of circles
what is that a tree I don't know it yeah
yeah I guess this is the frigging mazes
what this is these are the forest of
Methuselah so obviously there's gonna be
a Methuselah see oh god there's gonna be
a precipice in front how do I jumped I
don't even know how to jump I don't
think I can jump oh there's no jump I
would have just fallen in the precipice
anyway huh
dude tap oh I'm here okay well Elise is
a familiar place so if I put this away
can I jump fight oh there's like a
different budget how would you do he's a
life gym again
what is that egg triangle like switches
your stance to do like a different thing
that's empower times X you liked you uh
yeah no square is square so what square
is lecture don't ask me questions I have
no idea what sex do uh exercise nothing
as far as I can see
interesting yeah all right dude
well there's a nice lovely house whoa
I'm someone there I can talk to kill Oh
what gimme your purse are you who am I
we over doesn't matter just help me open
this door I should yeah why I packed my
tools in here seeing it was vacant
uh-huh mm-hmm but now somebody's gotten
locked at all you mean the person who
owns the house I should go in that
window that's open right there you know
right here immediately a job they can't
easily Oh what about this window that
you could easily fit into just jump in
there oh I can't
I'm here to impress on us I got a soul
we're gonna sue can I eat it
I don't know what you do well maybe it
makes you look prettier if you get more
Souls yeah am I pretty yet oh you're
gorgeous
yeah y'all just darlin God yeah they're
pretty
oh look like a barge in on ten would
time that people that I could talk
Undead aren't you how are you do this
you don't say this my way I don't smell
girl a bit my rotting oh you smell
Undead
oh it doesn't kind of this is marijuana
it's a kind of settlement a place where
life is almost normal
no oh I can exit oh I'm sorry I didn't
mean it three deaths worldwide that's
cuz I think I'm actually offline cuz I
couldn't sign in to the network for some
reason there's been three deaths at
least we can keep track oh that's a save
point over here I got a gone to her much
sooner
Oh light that ball
start the foil I thought we didn't light
it but then we did light it cuz we liar
going in a dark room Toba don't die
again but there's a same point right
outside that we'll be fine
I'm gonna be fine nothing you don't
around death oh yeah I think so Wow no
why no what's the wish I could have it
Marga sure did it I thought that was
gonna be a lot into that I didn't care
something really roll out on me fallin
crushy yeah me me let me do you know who
cares don't know if that's gonna close
with me boy that's a good time waster
there to open that dingdong damn door Oh
bridge
the roofer all right what do you got for
me oh it's down here what is it it's
dirt oh I got a tree giant thing I got
you you can plant your seeds in them
right whoa hey Steve knack I just test
again
just testing yeah just testing it out of
energy okay go ah
good give me your soul bloody block okay
okay there's a lot more than wanted whoa
he's just whoa calm down there friend oh
no needed lair McGee that's like a
lumberjack what is he doing out here
the trees are your friends you don't
even have a what wow why did you [ __ ]
yeah old whoa whoa nice dog look that
guy just eat what is hitting me
something eating me
oh my god is something enemy please
don't hit me I need to I'm gonna live
the cross Elijah aren't you - you're
sure hold on God Lord ah can't hit me
dodged radhaji I am dr. Jill did you not
see me dodging there did but touch more
Oh Oh God Oh
I don't get
got hard an archer I'll get him whoa
miss me now behind you oh yes about
infidel new but I got it that's good
credit like in those rage-inducing as I
thought you're doing well doing real
good real orders never play this game or
okay but what everyone else in the world
is a bad game around obviously yeah
that's the truth it's the dodge dodge
dodge bingo darn gosh what the doc gosh
Dingle darn that guy looks like some of
the night God good lord you know from I
don't know follow I cut him off at the
pass you lumberjack son of a [ __ ] you
ain't gonna get me this time
oh you got me that time but not this
time numbers oh my goodness gracious
don't stop pick up I'm not picking up an
item now that you say what was that of
death I'm almost that whole life I'm
gonna run out of those life times I know
I like the as you go thank you thank you
think there's an archer like way up
there broken straight sword might be
better than my attack straight toward
you never know well I got a home in hot
air aren't sure whatever he can't hit me
if he tried what all old are gonna watch
your health bars what all older I'm
gonna talk to this guy oh he's dead he's
got arrows in his yeah I buy guys dead
the guy is dead dead can i light this on
fire doesn't look like it looks like you
should be able to you but mmm not dodge
oh he was gonna get me I knew it okay
that was a life thousands take those now
away now what I intended oh nice thank
you I know it was nice thank you for
acknowledging that it was nice but I
already hi
I already knew I'm here to be
encouraging and I already was AI already
oh my god
god I already knew that yeah I already
know what I didn't want to squeeze a
life gem
stop stop squeezing a life gem stop by
doing it you said oh no and then why
does that why why why
just die already one more come on
Oh dead okay I did that quite well good
lord
oh yeah boots keep a listen I think I
did that way well we just all they go as
a reward for my good work and then I'll
go on my very own leg
oh what'd I get bolt I'm actually gonna
see you like ways that my inventory
uneasiness so what do you save a shut up
okay Gary Ford for Parenthood oh god get
on the menu who's not another life down
why are you pressing square mean - I
think that's attack for some reason I'm
not using good boy why not use do it
oh you dropped an actual item so that's
nice ah bro you got armor on ah you
heard a lot nope nope I didn't think
though yeah yeah I killed him I killed
him so dead I killed him so dead he's
dead now and I killed him he got down on
his knees when you killed him Annie
filthy good I'll do anything
hello Archer friend I do oh whoa why
fire come from I don't know
do I squeeze a life gem god damn throw
fireballs you do ow ah you
fire-breathing bastard
everything a strap has a trap